what is up welcome to the 11th PHP
tutorial I'm afraid I'm always going to
say Python anyway um building off a
switch but i forgot to mention one more
thing you could have multiple cases so
you could say like case one like let's
say we got rid of Gianni and we could
say case one and then you could have a
semicolon and then you can do case
Johnny like that so you could
theoretically have multiple cases like
great so let's save this save that pop
on over and we'll refresh and you can
see case one is called so you can you
can like if you're going to echo or are
usually what you're going to do is you
know perform some code so if you're
going to perform the same code whether
it's case one or case Johnny then you
can just do this and save yourself some
lines I just forgot to mention that so
there it is now so now you really know
everything there is to know about
switches so now let's discuss something
a little more fun and that's going to be
raised now an array is just like it's a
variable and it's got multiple elements
saved to that variable and then what you
can do is reference just one of the
elements at a time or maybe like a span
of those elements like the first 20
elements of that array and so on and the
arrays with in PHP there's actually
three different types of arrays so I'm
just going to do the first one here and
then we'll do the next ones next but
there is just like a typical what you
would think of as an array where it's
just like a one-dimensional is just it's
you define a variable and they need to
find a bunch of quote-unquote i would
say parts to that variable which can be
referenced
next though there are associative arrays
where you define the array and then you
define the parts of the array and then
you define like a part of that part
basically or you give a value to that
part if you have any idea about Python
it's it's up quite similar to a Python
dictionary where you have the you know
defining of the dictionary would be the
definition of the array then you've got
you know part one which would be the key
and then part two is the value and the
reven referred to as the same things
with it like keys and values in PHP so
if you understand dictionaries you'll
understand associative arrays and then
finally you have the ability to have a
multi-dimensional array so in theory you
could almost make like a database out of
a multi-dimensional array that's like
it's like a spreadsheet back practically
so anyway we'll get into each of those
and really like the purposes of each of
those but for now let's just do a
typical over it so we'll just say a
typical array equals and to define an
array you literally right out array and
then you have a parentheses and within
the array you specify the things within
the array so we'll just we're going to
have four parts to this array and we'll
just say purple part 1 then we'll say
part 2 part 3 and part or semicolon
remember in those now to show you what
you can do an array is if you call what
happens when we call up typical all read
and spell it correctly save pop on over
here refresh and we actually gotten oops
sorry wait let's let's let's echo it so
refresh and you see we get this line it
just says array
and so you kind of want to know it like
okay well what's in here so now we're
going to run on back to print the print
function and within the print function
you have print R and this would be a
time to use print are now print or is
exactly that it's a function so within
the function you put the what you want
to apply that to so you put the actual
variable in here now this is really more
so you can like visualize as you code
but it's still pretty useful to print it
out from time and time so anyway you can
use print underscore or and when we
refresh now you're presented with a more
visually appealing one like it tells you
the zeroeth element applies to one the
first element to second element 3 and so
yeah if you're not familiar with
ordering within programming the first
element is classified as 0 the second
element 1 and so on but it starts at
zero not at one so that's your typical
your typical array and then what you can
do with this later on is you can call
specific parts like let's say you want
to do suit long cast echo and then you
typical array and you want to just
reference like one of the elements
within here you can reference element 0
or something like that and so we'll save
this and we'll run this and we'll see
what it spits out at us and it spits out
part 1 because it spits out 0 with
element which is part 1 now in a pretty
future video or pretty near future video
I'll be showing you kind of one of the
main benefits to in a rhyme in my
experience using arrays is most useful
to use an array with a for loop or
rather if it's in PHP for each loop and
you use you run through like for each
element in this array do
up this and with an array you can
actually append remove whatever items
from the array it's a mutable list but
we'll get in more into that later on but
for now this is just a typical array if
you want to append something to this
array it's really quite simple you just
define say like as you as you saw before
we called it by typing typical rain and
put something in the square brackets you
can do this by going typical array and
you see we have a zero one two three so
we can say the fourth element and this
array equals well it only makes sense
for us a 45 and now let us let's print
out the full one now so we'll say print
R and we want to do this to typical ray
save that pop over here refresh as you
can see it actually added that part to
our race so that's how you'll add two
arrays so that's a typical array as
always thanks for watching thank you for
your support your subscriptions and it's
a list I'm